why does the empire have a religion
let me pull up this story that is that
is directly related to what ian is
talking about timcast.com reports boston
police launch hate crime investigation
after teenagers attack white woman with
braids the attack is the latest in a
series of crimes committed by juveniles
in the city's district a1 and i was also
add this has nothing to do with what ian
was talking about yeah but you're right
segway awesome
i was like can i do the worst possible
segue
uh i thought this story was interesting
because we've been seeing an increase in
crime we've also been seeing wokeness
going crazy so when there was a report
that they're like it's racially
motivated because the woman was white
and she had braids these guys basically
attacked her because she was culturally
appropriating braids
and the city is saying it's a hate crime
is that what it's can you read that bit
so they said uh the boston police are
investigating a possible racially
motivated crime after a group of
teenagers attacked a woman in the city's
downtown the headline is a white woman
with braids but was it because she had
braids that's so that's that's the
initial reporting i saw
is that police noted in the report the
woman was in distress and highly
animated oh here we go the girls
allegedly punched and kicked the woman
and pulled her by the hair because she
was uh here we go
one of the victims said a group of girls
called her a white expletive with braids
who should not wear her hair in that
style because she was not black before
assaulting her the girls allegedly
punched and kicked the woman and pulled
her by her hair
okay so if this never actually happened
and instead
uh
a leftist invented a story of this
happening to a black person like
completely fabricated uh a hate crime
like this it would be in the national
news cycle for days and days
no they're not going to talk about this
i always like pointing out that bill
maher a week after covington was
debunked still maintained the lie
because the dude just like doesn't know
how to google stuff
i get nervous about the term hate crime
it seems like it's too subjective i i
like that it's finally being used both
ways though like there was just a
calgary police tweet where it was just
some graffiti that said like fy people
why people shouldn't exist anymore and
they're like investigating a hate crime
and people were seething molding
comments and i was like well you know
what this is where we're at
it should be fair if they're going to
investigate it one way they have to do
it the other but that is giving in
to ridiculous laws
if they
i think we should have equality if you
attack someone you attack them
if it's just like well we think you did
it for a specific reason related to like
how they looked now you get worse
punishment i'm like dude assault assault
battery is battery motivations
it's it's it's it's it's weird in my
opinion i don't like hate crime i
remember that um new york subway attack
like a few weeks ago where the guy shot
like 26 people or something no one died
ten people like ten people okay terrible
they were like we're investigating this
this is not but we believe it is not an
act of terrorism i'm like what the guy
terrorized everyone on the train that's
terror i don't care use the word or
don't but it's like that they're using
that word like hate crime terror attack
to make it more dangerous but it's like
how do you know it was crazy every
headline would be like oh if the if it
were the other way right like a white
guy who shot up the place they'd be like
if this were a brown man they'd call it
a terror attack like that's so true
every time yeah they're very reluctant
to apply that label to anyone who isn't
white basically
i don't like it the terror attack thing
is new 20 years new i don't like it well
i mean it's terrorism right if i
understand properly the actual technical
definition of terrorism is you're trying
to use fear to get people to comply with
your political motive but it's so sorry
but these guys
this guy had posted a bunch of black
nationalist stuff yep like the joy that
when the canteen remember the antifa guy
who had the 9mm with the drum
and it was like in ohio or whatever do
you guys remember that they said that it
wasn't politically motivated they said
it wasn't leftist violence and i'm like
dude
i don't care what you think yeah if a
dude's posting crazy antifa stuff and
then goes and shoots people up my only
assumption is this is his driving
motivation yeah the world view he lives
in
now was the reason he pulled the trigger
was to enact communism i don't know he
was a far left extremist who engaged in
an act yeah he he had definitely
intentionally set it up and did it well
oh sorry i was thinking about you can
literally be a terrorist as long as
you're on the left though and they just
won't mention it do you know dr tedros
the head of the world health
organization i just found out last week
he was literally a member of a banned
terror organization
yeah the ted gray people's liberation
army look it up right now uh dr tedros
he's the guy who we got all our updates
for from the world health organization
on covid uh
it's
people's liberation go to his wikipedia
and look at early life and it just says
that uh oh he was a part of this little
group uh the tigre rebels and then if
you click he denies his name
no he was literally a part of their
political party for years he was even
been accused of supplying arms they
killed a bunch of people they were a
banned party in ethiopia oh yeah for
terrorism tedros was a member of the
tigray people's liberation front the
leading group in a coalition of
movements known as the ethiopian
people's revolutionary democratic front
in a successful bid to overthrow
mengistu hail merriam now click on tigre
people's liberation front notice how
they don't mention in that sentence at
all that it's a terror organization no
no it's an ethnic nationalist
organization paramilitary group and
banned political party
can you imagine if any of us were a part
of that what our wikipedia page would
look like it sure as hell wouldn't be a
single sentence not mentioning ethnic
nationalist terrorists or band but they
just whoo
well i mean they included the head of
the world health organization
that's insane that is i think it's not
like unbelievable forgiveness and like
it's not unbelievable when someone's
radicalized who was it we had on the
show uh when someone's radicalized when
they're young and they're in terror
organizations oh my goodness
was like for like 10 or 12 years he was
like a hardcore basically doing what
this guy was doing and then snapped out
of it and was like and basically now
he's talking about de-radicalization and
stuff he's big talks a lot about the
azov and ukraine and how we're if we're
funding that we're funding a radical
ethnic
you know cleansive group um so maybe you
know i don't want to like this guy i'm
not a big fan of the world health
organization but i'm not
just because he was in an organization
when he was younger doesn't mean that he
wasn't younger he was like a politician
a part of this group like an adult and
the it's the point isn't even like him
about him personally it's
the fact that this isn't mentioned
anywhere that he can become the head of
the world health organization with no
fuss about the fact that he was part of
a terrorist oh yeah imagine noise talks
openly about his experiences if he was
hiding it that'd be a completely
different story
yeah yep no it's insane put the camera
on me i mean i mean you know i try to
drink your drink sorry yeah i mean no
i'm eating maraschino cherries of course
yeah community what were you going to
say seamus well i was going to mention
something earlier but now this is the
ira
exactly hold on
um
i knew i knew someone was going to go
there i don't know what i'm doing to
inviting this invite this kind of what's
that what's that orange there's nothing
it's nothing yeah what is that i only
see so anyway
[Laughter]
uh no i mean of course this guy's
facebook page as you mentioned her
social media accounts were filled with a
bunch of left-wing rhetoric and their
argument is uh i actually don't even
really make an argument about it they
just don't say anything but that's
ridiculous i mean if somebody committed
uh a massacre in their social media was
full of them posting things like the
goblins watch me and like the voices
tell me to shoot people we wouldn't
assume that that was unrelated to them
going out and hurting people and yet
when someone's posting like incendiary
insane left-wing
rhetoric that's just not even a
potential motivation for why they would
go out and kill people once they do you
know look i can't speak for right-wing
channels
i don't know
but um
when when
you have these prominent left-wing
podcasts just outright lie about all of
this stuff they'll be like you know
you'll mention this look like no he
isn't you'll be he's a member of the
group no noise not and you're like i'm
reading about it right now no you're not
like the taylor lorenz thing is just
yeah hey you know they linked to her
private address no they didn't
yeah they did
it's not her home okay well it is but
it's also her work i guess it's a work i
just said that's your argument no no
they didn't no they debunked him they
don't do that
it's just like what's the point of even
trying to talk to these people i'm just
going to say right now i've said it
before i'll say it again what's the
point of negotiating with someone who
will look at like they'll look at this
bottle i'll say i have a glass bottle
and then go no you don't
i'm literally holding a glass pop no
you're not
okay
well if we can't agree on something i'm
literally doing then i don't know what's
the point of talking only to like um
measure emotions to like tone them down
or tone down yourself only to listen to
their feelings it's most about feelings
with people like that now it says that
teddros was a member of this group but
what does it say about lauren southern
oh oh let's not read my we don't we
don't read my wikipedia page okay tim
this is good make sure i read it sure
yeah lauren southern is 26. oh wow wow
ancient way too young the 90s uh a
canadian alt-right youtuber what does
that even mean alt-right i mean wow
nationalist they took out white
nationalists since our last episode
congratulations look what happens you
highlight alt-right
it doesn't matter
how nice hello
wow
wikipedia is a joke yeah but uh what
does it say about south africa up there
something about this one
um
she has been described as an advocate of
white genocide conspiracy theory for her
documentary farmlands you know what the
conclusion of farmlands is that there
isn't a white genocide but that we're
approaching steps where we have rhetoric
in government saying we need to kill
white people which i think pretty fair
right if government elected officials
are saying we need to kill boar that
steps towards genocide yeah
so like they they say i promote the
conspiracy theory
which i don't but whatever you know
i've heard a lot about it this is the
farm attacks where
white farmers were getting attacked in
south africa because they thought you're
colonialists and we kind of thing yeah
there's like
massive uh groups at the eff black land
first that literally just advocate
killing and taking the land from the
boar they have songs about it that
they've sung like full-on hate speech
farmers just getting murdered on their
property for the crime of being white
and owning land like it's horrendous and
you know racism is a problem all around
in that country amongst all groups like
different
ethnic groups like within just the
african context tribal groups are super
racist against each other that's like
very much a norm there unfortunately but
like
to not acknowledge
that it's happening in a political
context
is wild to me especially in the west
it's so obvious and out there too one
second of google but i guess as you
mentioned tim these people don't
understand how google works i guess they
don't have access to their own computer
they just lie
i have a slightly off-topic statement
i'd like to make seamus you said earlier
that you're from ireland or you're no
i'm not i'm not this is the thing
why are you doing this people are gonna
like start calling me a pose right never
claim this my question is i it sounds
like ireland is how you would say the
word island with an irish accent ireland
oh it's entirely ireland ah it's
interesting is that real i don't know oh
that was my question i don't i don't
think
irish songs
what are you doing this is unbelievable
i want to let everyone know that i was
just smeared by white nationalist
lawrence southern for my ethnic identity
i watched it happen yeah exactly i was
like six feet away as a non-white man
definitely it's very effective
definitely the british were like those
are people on the island there was a
meme recently released uh they they can
track the data of um on google the most
searched countries within countries in
europe and it was showing like oh
ukraine is being the most searched
country outside of people's own country
in every country in europe except
one place
ireland and guess what their most
searched country was british
watch your back it was they they're most
search countries
england british empire they're like
under the boot of the british empire
basically they don't want their back
from what i can tell a lot of them never
even so what does it mean
the ira and the irish was it an
attempted revolution that they wanted
freedom from britain and like half the
country got it and the other half is
still british i don't know lauren's the
expert on this the uh
i'm the i am by no means anyway an
expert no very little but uh you know
ireland was what uh enslaved by the
british for 800 years was it 800
yeah british colonists yeah and so they
were like not happy with it yeah but uh
lots of catholics killed lots of but the
north was uh the orange is like the
orange order i think that that's
something to do with the dutch doesn't
it hmm that was protestant yeah that's
my understanding is that the orange
always represented the the protestants
the brits oh okay yeah yeah there you go
uh now you know uh i was there with you
wasn't i yeah when they were doing the
burnings yeah that was cool that was
really wild the the peace wall makes no
sense but you guys were in ireland
together we were in ireland no one
invited me
on that day
we'll accuse him of being some kind of
irish terrorist on the podcast but to
actually go to ireland now he doesn't he
doesn't need to well they were burning
the irish flag on these like giant
pallets like built
insanely high um
it's like july the 7th or something i
can't remember but it was like a
northern irish holiday where they just
like burn effigies of british
politicians
the peace wall made no sense because
like one side was like pro-palestine and
one side was pro-israel and you're like
what does that have to do with what's
going on it's the foreign funding going
into each side no it's just tribalism
yeah it got to the point where this is
what that one was telling us he was like
if one side adopted a principle or idea
the other side would take the opposite
just for the sake of taking the opposite
well then yeah they had like obama and
nelson mandela on the irish side of the
wall and then they had yeah all this
like right-wing stuff on the northern
irish side it was really weird
come from like trying not to get to hear
people not to go to the other side
you're like no everything they're saying
is wrong don't even think about it it's
like right now yeah when a leftist will
say to me
washington post didn't dox anybody and
i'll be like here's a link to them no
they didn't it's like they just have to
say that because they're in a cult they
go i know you are but what am i
quite right and i'm like dude you're in
a car i got no point talking to you
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there